Ça y est c'est l'hiver, il fait froid, normal,
et dans les bulletins météo
on va donc à nouveau voir fleurir les
fameuses "températures ressenties".
Alors ce qui est bien c'est que c'est
toujours super alarmiste, hein
Ça donne un petit côté film catastrophe
au bulletin météo.
Mais est-ce que c'est bien scientifique
comme concept, ça,
la "température ressentie" ?
Eh bien, plus ou moins.
On va voir que l'idée de départ
peut paraître pertinente,
mais qu'en pratique,
ça ne marche pas du tout.
[thème musical]
La raison principale qui fait que c'est
compliqué de parler de température "ressentie",
c'est que le fait
qu'on ait chaud ou froid
n'est PAS une question de température.
Ça vous paraît bizarre
comme affirmation ?
Et bien faisons
une petite expérience de pensée :
Imaginez que vous soyez chez vous
et qu'à l'intérieur
il fasse 25°C.
Alors à 25°C on est bien, on peut
être à poil, et même sans s'agiter
ou faire d'effort physique particulier,
on n'a pas froid.
On peut rester toute la journée comme ça.
Maintenant imaginez que vous preniez
un bain dont l'eau est à 25°C.
Faites l'essai, hein, c'est jouable.
Vous n'aurez pas trop mal à y rentrer,
Mais assez rapidement
vous allez avoir froid.
Je doute que vous y restiez
plus d'une heure,
surtout si vous ne faites pas d'effort physique particulier comme on le ferait la piscine.
C'est bizarre non ?
25°C dans les deux cas :
dans l'air on est bien toute la journée
et dans l'eau on finit vite par cailler.
Et bien cette petite expérience
illustre un truc important
Pour le ressenti, la température,
on s'en fout.
Ce qui compte c'est le flux.
Le flux, c'est la quantité de chaleur
qui quitte votre corps
au cours du temps.
Et c'est ce qui va faire
que vous allez avoir froid ou pas.
Evidemment, ce flux (on va le noter "F")
a quand même un lien avec la température extérieure :
Il est proportionnel à la différence de température
entre votre peau, qui est à environ 35 °C,
et le milieu extérieur.
Mais pour calculer le flux,
on doit diviser cette différence de température
par un coefficient
qu'on appelle
la "résistance thermique de surface".
Cette résistance exprime le fait que les échanges
de chaleur à la surface de votre peau
ne se font pas de façon parfaite et instantanée.
Plus la résistance est élevée,
plus le flux sera faible.
Le flux c'est donc l'écart de
température divisé la résistance.
Et pour ceux qui connaissent la loi d'Ohm
en électricité, I = U /R
C'est un peu analogue.
Evidemment la question maintenant,
c'est "combien vaut cette résistance ?"
Et bien quand vous êtes chez vous
à l'intérieur et à poil,
elle vaut environ 0,15.
Donc pour une différence de température de 10°C
entre votre peau et l'air,
on peut brancher ça dans le calcul,
et ça fait un flux d'environ 65 W/m²
Alors oui le flux c'est par mètre carré
car ça dépend de la surface totale
de peau exposée.
Pour un être humain adulte,
on est à un peu plus d'un mètre carré et demi.
Donc ça va faire au total environ
100 watts.
100 W, c'est donc la puissance thermique
qui s'échappe de votre corps
quand vous êtes à poil chez vous par 25°C.
Et ça correspond à peu près aussi à la chaleur
produite par votre organisme
du fait de votre métabolisme.
Des calories que vous brûlez quand vous êtes au repos.
Et donc dans ces conditions,
il y a un équilibre entre la chaleur
produite par votre corps
et celle qui s'échappe dans l'air extérieur.
Vous n'avez ni froid ni chaud,
vous pouvez rester aussi longtemps
que vous voulez comme ça.
Maintenant quand vous êtes
dans un bain à 25°C,
le calcul est similaire
mais la résistance de surface est beaucoup plus faible.
La raison, c'est que les échanges
de chaleur se font beaucoup mieux
entre la peau et l'eau qu'entre la peau et l'air.
Les valeurs exactes de résistance dépendrait
beaucoup de la forme de votre corps,
de la baignoire, du mouvement de l'eau, etc.
Mais on peut prendre une valeur typique de 0,01.
Mettez ça dans le calcul vous
voyez que ça nous fait 1000 W/m²
Cette fois ci, la chaleur qui s'échappe
de votre corps est bien supérieure
à ce que produit votre métabolisme au repos.
Donc votre organisme va commencer à
brûler beaucoup plus de calories
pour essayer de compenser,
et il va vous
envoyer un signal physiologique
de ce déséquilibre :
c'est la sensation de froid.
Au total si on compare 25°C dans l'air et dans l'eau,
c'est la même température
et pourtant pas du tout la même sensation.
Parce que ce qui compte,
ce n'est pas la température, c'est le flux.
Alors petite astuce pour les amateurs,
pour la même raison,
vous refroidirez beaucoup plus
vite une bouteille de vin en la mettant
dans un seau avec de la glace et un peu
d'eau qu'en la mettant au congélateur.
Au delà de ça, il existe un autre exemple qui illustre très bien la prépondérance du flux :
C'est le fait qu'on attribue à certains matériaux le fait d'être chaud ou froid quand on les touche.
Par exemple le carrelage c'est considéré comme froid, alors que le polystyrène on dirait que c'est chaud.
Et donc c'est plus agréable de poser le pied nu sur du polystyrène que sur du carrelage.
Mais qu'est ce qu'il se passe si on pose un glaçon sur ces deux matériaux ?
Et bien, si le polystyrène paraît plus chaud on peut s'attendre à ce que le glaçon fonde plus vite.
Et bien vous pouvez faire l'expérience,
voici ce que vous verrez :
Hé oui, c'est l'inverse qui se produit !
Le glaçon fond plus vite sur le carrelage.
La raison c'est que le polystyrène
n'est pas plus chaud que le carrelage.
En fait ils sont tous les deux à la température ambiante, donc environ 20°C.
Mais le carrelage a une meilleure capacité à échanger de la chaleur que le polystyrène.
Les flux sont donc toujours plus importants.
Si je pose ma main à 37°C sur du carrelage
et du polystyrène,
le carrelage absorbera plus de chaleur :
d'où la sensation de froid.
Mais si c'est un glaçon à 0°C,
cette fois-ci, le carrelage donnera plus de chaleur que le polystyrène, et le glaçon fondera plus vite.
Et pourtant les deux surfaces sont
toujours à la même température.
Encore une autre illustration du fait que ce qui compte fondamentalement,
ça n'est pas la température,
c'est le flux.
Alors revenons maintenant à notre météo.
Je vous ai dit que pour calculer le flux,
on divisait l'écart de température par
la résistance de surface.
Et que celle ci vaut environ
0,15 pour l'air en intérieur.
Mais si vous sortez dehors, ça change. L'air extérieur est toujours beaucoup plus en mouvement
que l'air intérieur : il a des petites turbulences, et surtout il peut y avoir carrément du vent.
En l'absence de vent la résistance est légèrement inférieure à celle en intérieur :
environ 0,1. Mais plus la vitesse du vent est élevée, plus cette valeur va diminuer.
la courbe que vous voyez ici représente la diminution de la résistance de surface au fur et à mesure
de l'augmentation de la vitesse du vent.
Par exemple avec un vent à 50 km/h,
la résistance n'est déjà plus que de 0,05.
Alors comparons deux situations :
d'un côté 25°C et pas de vent,
et de l'autre, 25°C aussi mais avec 50 km/h de vent.
Et calculons le flux dans les deux cas
puisque c'est ça qui compte.
Donc première situation, 10°C de
différence, une résistance de 0,1 :
ça fait 100 W/m² de flux. Dans le deuxième cas la résistance n'est que de 0,05. Ça fait 200 W/m² de flux.
À température identique, on perd deux fois plus de chaleur du fait de ce vent.
Pour traduire ce rôle du vent, on pourrait s'amuser à donner la météo en flux plutôt qu'en température.
Sauf que ça n'est pas très pratique ni très intuitif.
Alors ce qu'on peut faire c'est prendre notre situation à 25°C, 50 km/h de vent,
et se demander quelle température il faudrait pour que l'on perde le même flux mais en l'absence de vent.
Et bien on peut faire le calcul rapidement : c'est 15°C.
Avec 15°C et pas de vent on perdrait aussi 200 W/m²
La même chose qu'avec 25°C et 50 km/h de vent.
Puisque le ressenti physiologique est lié
principalement au flux,
une manière de l'exprimer, c'est de dire qu'à 25°C
et 50 km/h de vent,
on "ressent" la même chose qu'à 15°C sans vent.
Et que donc 15°C, c'est en quelque sorte
la température "ressentie" : celle qui donnerait le même flux en l'absence de vent.
Alors ce petit principe de traduire les flux en température "ressentie", il fonctionne quelle que soit la température
et la vitesse du vent : à partir des formules on peut s'amuser à faire un petit diagramme
qui exprime la température "ressentie" en fonction de la température de l'air et la vitesse du vent.
Dans la situation que j'ai prise, le vent conduisait à une température "ressentie" 10°C plus basse
que la température de l'air. Et voyez que pour des températures plus froides de ça peut être bien pire.
Alors vous trouvez peut-être ces valeurs
exagérément basses et vous avez raison :
l'explication c'est que je suis toujours dans mon hypothèse où on est complètement à poil.
Or en pratique c'est pas vraiment le cas, surtout quand la température est plus basse.
Et le fait de s'habiller va complètement
changer le calcul.
Quand on s'habille chaudement, qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
On ne change pas la température extérieure
mais on s'isole du froid.
Physiquement on diminue le flux.
Pour prendre ça en compte dans notre calcul,
c'est très simple. Les vêtements
ajoute une résistance thermique supplémentaire qu'il suffira d'additionner.
On additionne les résistances,
un peu comme en électricité.
Dans le calcul du flux, on doit prendre en compte la somme de la résistance de surface de tout à l'heure,
et de la résistance des vêtements. Celle ci va dépendre principalement de leur épaisseur,
et pour une couche d'environ 1 cm,
on va être autour de 0,4.
Donc en l'absence de vent la résistance sera de
0,1 + 0,4 : ça fait 0,5 au total,
et avec 50 km/h de vent, elle sera de
0,05 + 0,4 soit 0,45
Vous voyez que ça ne fait plus une grosse différence entre les deux situations.
Tout à l'heure la présence du vent divisait la résistance de surface par deux. Mais avec des vêtements,
elle l'a fait seulement baisser de 10%.
Alors prenons une situation concrète :
Supposons qu'on soit habillé avec des habits ayant cette valeur de résistance thermique
et que la température de l'air extérieur soit de 10°C. En l'absence de vent on peut calculer le flux
avec une résistance totale de 0,5 donc.
Et on trouve 50 W/m²
Prenons ensuite la même situation mais
avec 50 km/h de vent.
La résistance totale et cette fois de seulement 0,45
et le calcul du flux donne 55 W/m²
On peut alors chercher la température "ressentie", c'est à dire celle qui donne ce même flux de 55 W/m²
mais en l'absence de vent.
Et la bonne réponse c'est 7,5°C. Avec 7,5°C sans vent,
on perd le même flux que 10°C avec 50 km/h de vent.
On peut s'amuser à mettre à jour
mon petit diagramme de tout à l'heure
qui montre la température "ressentie" en fonction de la température de l'air et de la vitesse du vent.
Vous voyez que quand on prend en compte
l'impact des habits, la baisse de température "ressentie"
due au vent est loin d'être aussi importante.
Et ce serait encore plus faible
si on augmentait la couche de vêtements.
Donc si vous êtes bien couvert, la température "ressentie", on s'en fout un peu.
Alors évidemment la réalité est
un peu moins idéale que ça
d'une part parce qu'on suppose les vêtements étanches au vent, ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
suivant comment vous êtes habillé.
Et aussi bien sûr parce qu'il y a des parties de votre corps qui peuvent ne pas être couvertes,
notamment le visage et les mains.
Et c'est surtout pour ces parties-là
que considérer le vent est important.
Notamment parce qu'il augmente
considérablement le risque de gelures.
Mais comme vous pouvez vous en douter, cela varie énormément d'un individu à l'autre.
Suivant sa peau, sa pilosité, la surface exposée, etc. Alors prétendre définir une "température ressentie"
objective, c'est un peu sans espoir. Surtout qu'on l'a vu, ça ne concerne que la peau exposée.
Pour les parties couvertes et donc la sensation générale de froid, et bien on s'en fiche un peu.
Et surtout ça peut conduire à plein de confusions :
Par exemple s'il fait 2°C mais -5°C en ressenti,
est-ce que l'eau dans une bouteille risque de geler ?
Et bien non, elle se refroidira plus vite
que s'il n'y avait pas de vent mais elle deviendra pas plus froide que 2°C, la température de l'air.
Enfin pour finir, il y a un autre facteur qui
complique les choses, mais cette fois dans l'autre sens.
C'est le soleil. Les rayons du soleil qui viennent éventuellement vous frapper
contribuent eux aussi au flux, mais positivement :
Ils vous apportent de la chaleur
donc ils vont faire augmenter la température "ressentie".
Le flux que vous recevez du soleil va dépendre de plusieurs facteurs : sa hauteur dans le ciel,
qui varie avec l'heure et la latitude, votre orientation par rapport à lui, la couleur de vos vêtements
ou de votre peau, etc. Et suivant les situations ça peut aller d'une dizaine de watts à presque 300 W/m²
Vous voyez donc que même habillé légèrement, dans certains cas le flux positif dû au soleil
peut venir compenser le flux négatif dû à la température de l'air et au vent. C'est ce qui explique
qu'on peut ne pas avoir froid à la montagne si on est à
midi au soleil.
En bref définir une température ressentie qui ait physiquement et physiologiquement un sens
est complètement impossible. Alors plutôt que de vouloir faire du sensationnalisme,
il me semble plus pertinent de donner l'ensemble des informations météorologiques :
la température de l'air, l'humidité car elle joue un rôle aussi, notamment par forte chaleur,
la vitesse du vent, l'ensoleillement, etc.
Et laissons les gens s'adapter en fonction
de leurs propres caractéristiques et de leur vécu.
Et on pourrait simplement accompagner ça
d'un indice d'alerte pour prévenir les dangers de gelures dûs à la combinaison
de températures très basses et de vents importants. L'indice pourrait très bien être gradué de 0 à 5
sans avoir besoin d'invoquer des
"températures ressenties" n'ayant aucun sens.
[musique de générique]
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, si ces notions vous intéresse
je donne des détails sur les principes thermiques dans le billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo.
Vous pouvez également aller voir une vidéo de Scilabus qui présente notamment l'historique des formules
un peu ésotériques qui sont utilisées aujourd'hui pour calculer certaines de ces "températures ressenties".
Sur la chaîne de String Theory j'avais également fait un épisode pour évoquer ces notions,
et de façon générale le concept de "confort thermique".
Voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner, de mettre la cloche, tout ça, pour ne rien rater
des publications de la chaîne.
Facebook et Twitter, c'est pour les actus,
et je vous dis à très bientôt pour des nouvelles vidéos !